[Music]  another one of our favorite couples is  Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively and you  know it's gotta be uncomfortable  watching your spouse on screen with  another woman but Blake can rest easy on  this one because in Ryan's new movie the  hit man's bodyguard  he just can't quit samuel l.jackson my  job is to keep you out of harm's way  [Laughter]  then the action comedy Ryan is a  protection agent hired to keep Samuels  notorious hitman safe it's kind of like  the bodyguard what a bromance and in the  beginning the reluctant duo doesn't  exactly see I die whatever without me  your body's useful as a condom in the  convent from exploding cars to a boat  chase on a canal in Amsterdam only et  can take you behind the scenes look now  at three ready woman I said by three you  shot early yeah well they did Salma  Hayek co-stars as Samuels wife in the  movie out this August we're late what  happens in a seatbelt rule  [Music]  you